même circonscription c'est presque la
nièvre avec plus de 300 communes c'est
l'une des plus grandes de bourgogne
morvan cantons ruraux
elle s'étend sur l'intégralité du
département à l'exception de nevers et
du val de loire député socialiste
sortant tête d'affiche des frondeurs
christian paul il brigue un cinquième
mandat sans lassitude avec la volonté de
continuer à faire entendre la voix de la
nièvre
j'en vois beaucoup des maisons de santé
avec celle là on l'attend depuis un
moment
mesure aussi un candidat son
enthousiasme à sa capacité à innover à
renouveler aussi les pratiques
démocratiques
je vais mettre en place je crois que
c'est une première en france un conseil
citoyen 21 nivernaise nivernais des
volontaires tirés au sort pour
m'accompagner dans ce mandat pour débat
des principaux projets de loi ça c'est
du renouvellement
face à lui la république en arche mis
sur un candidat qui le connaît bien
patrice perron chef d'une entreprise
d'ambulance à 2,6 et fils de l'ancien
suppléant de christian paul son esprit
frondeur à basculer les équilibres nous
à isoler d'autant plus moi au contraire
je pars sur un véritable projet
dynamique objectif je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un tas de problèmes
qu'on peut anticiper donc s'est posé
cette réflexion regarder là où on veut
aller et tourner les yeux vers l'avenir
la circonscription reste aussi
historiquement associé à françois
mitterrand élu ici pendant 19 ans un
héritage que veut bousculer le front
national avec des thèmes de campagne qui
porte auprès d'un électorat rural
il n'y a pas d'emploi il n'y a pas
d'emploi la crise de l'emploi et a pas
de service public ait pas de service de
transport mitterrand il aurait eu 100
ans l'an dernier est mort il ya une
année voilà faut se tourner la page nous
avons les mêmes élus locaux conseil
départemental au conseil régional les
mêmes députés qui cumulent des mandats
depuis trop longtemps qui eux ont
vraiment sclérosé la nièvre et moi je
veux apporter ce renouveau à gauche et
la france insoumise espère profiter avec
anne-marie mains de la déroute
présidentiel du ps jean luc mélenchon a
récolté ici près de 20% au premier tour
quand benoît hamon plafonné à 6 2 5%
nous avons vocation à porter la voix du
peuple dans la nièvre effectivement
parce que ça fait beaucoup trop
longtemps que toute personne ne la
portent
si le parti socialiste
a vécu ce qu'il a vécu au cours de la
dernière élection présidentielle c'est
pas du tout un hasard c'est parce qu'il
ya d'un côté le discours sofia de
l'autre côté les actes la droite quant à
elle se présente divisée sur un
territoire qui ne lui sourit pas depuis
20 ans investi par les républicains a ni
le grain devra affronter fabienne cardo
porte parole national de françois fillon
lors de la présidentielle
en rupture avec les instances
départementales du parti nous ne sommes
pas des dissidents nous sommes des
visages nouveaux
c'est à dire pas des apparatchiks du
pays ils pas des politiques qu'il faut
une carrière politique
nous sommes des gens de la société
civile et nous sommes des gagnants pas
des dissidents les gagnants toute façon
c'est toujours négatif à sa fin et les
voix qu'elle va remporter ça sera
d'autant des voix qu'elles seront
reportés à mon avis sur les socialistes
d'ailleurs reste un problème passer à
230 voix d'une élection au premier tour
en 2012 christian paul a cette fois bien
plus d'obstacles sur la route vers un
nouveau mandat à sa droite ou à sa
gauche ses adversaires espèrent faire
tomber ce bastion socialiste et il
pourrait bien être trois ou quatre ans
on découvre second tour pour une
triangulaire que dépendra de la
participation qui s'annonce faible ce
qui ne favorisera pas ces cas de figure
sont aussi candidats dans cette deuxième
circonscription de la nièvre patrick
20h05 monique choquel gilbert champagne
dominique dupuis bernard gagne-pain gens
de rohan chabot et henri massol